-You are here in studio!
-I'm here!
-This is the most energy
we've ever felt in the studio
since we got back to the studio.
-You and I know
how to bring the energy.
-I mean, are you used to
now walking out every day?
I mean, from doing the show
every day,
like, you have an entrance
every day?
-Yes. And our director, Adam,
you know, he was like,
"If you want to change it up
and walk from somewhere else,
there are no rules,"
and I was like, "Got it.
It really took you saying that
for me to realize that."
Like, I would have done
the same thing every day.
I always wanted to end the show
a certain way
and I finally found that with,
like, this thing, doggy bag.
We'll see if it works
'cause you said it too.
You try things, and some things
work and some things don't.
-What's doggy bag?
-It's something to take
with you.
-Oh!
-Like at a restaurant.
-Yes. Brilliant.
-I personally could live
a very happy life
if I was a personal curator.
Like, just let me curate
for you.
-Yeah.
-And that's what doggy bag is.
-Yeah. I feel like it's kind of
what your show is as well.
-It is a mood board.
It is a curation.
-It's so very you because you go
like, "Yeah, today I want to --
I want to talk to --"
You've launched that --
That kid star is gigantic.
-Jonah! Jonah Larson,
who did our pilot,
which was not a pilot,
let's face it.
It was an audition tape,
and he came in from Wisconsin
and did it with me.
And so we were able to get
to know each other in person,
which was great, so when
the show got picked up for real,
he was one of
my first phone calls.
I was like I meant what I said.
-This kid has got
personality plus.
He's a superstar.
But you have him.
Pilar, who, I mean, the chef.
-Pilar.
Pilar Valdes --
she's this extraordinary chef
who I hope soon
everyone will know,
and she's changed our lives,
and she's self-taught and cool.
-But every day you have someone
on the show where I go like,
"Ooh, that's someone
I've never heard of,"
and now they're part
of my world,
and I love that
you're doing that.
-I feel like it's --
it was such an opportunity
for me to -- again, that's
that curation of life.
I'm, like, I have found these
wonderful people in my journey
and if I could ever be
alongside of them,
then, really,
that's the whole point.
It's not, like, me presenting.
It's I want to stand next to
this person because I've --
I feel like life is better
with them in it.
-Do you like
doing the interviews?
-I love it.
-I think my favorite interview
that you did
was with your ex,
with Tom Green.
That was unbelievable.
-And that was -- There was
no questions prepared for that.
I had an offline conversation
with him because we didn't want
it to be some bougie Hollywood
moment like,
"Let's reconnect in front
of the cameras."
But that said,
I was, like, you know --
the thing that I love about Tom
was he is one of
the first people to have put
a camera on his life, you know,
when it was
a giant, fat camcorder
and there were
no easy phones available.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You know?
His stuff was on, like, VHS.
I remember watching
his VHS tapes.
And so it's what gave me
the idea, because I just said,
you know, "Gosh, would you want
to, you know, kind of reconnect?
I feel like it's been
a long time,
and I would just love
to honor what you did.
You broke down all these doors.
You are a pioneer.
And I would love
to talk about it
and have it be an excuse for us
to say hello."
That's the tone.
I sent him a video.
And then he sent me one back.
And immediately
he made me laugh,
and that's like my kryptonite.
-That's him.
-Laughter.
-It was fascinating.
It was fascinating TV.
If you have not seen it,
go on YouTube
or thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
and check out this clip.
It was just good.
It was different.
It was fresh and it was raw.
And I thought
that was fascinating.
I loved it.
-That means a lot
coming from you because I think
we're some of the least
"gotcha"-type of people.
-Yeah. No, no, no,
I don't do that at all.
-And I don't like doing it
and I don't want it done to me
and it's just not my wheelhouse.
And I just wanted to have a lot
of dignity and a gentle moment.
And it was nice to hear from
some people saying like,
"I'd like to have that with
someone from my past,"
you know, whether it was
a specific person.
A lot of people were talking
about how they'd like to have
that kind of exchange
from someone who, you know,
they had a significant chapter
of their life with.
-Yeah, I think that's probably
the thing about your show
is that daytime different
than late night,
but you kind of want to spark
a conversation
and keep that going.
I mean, and you did it.
But you know what else you did
that I was so impressed
and I already told you
and Chris Miller.
I go, "How did you do
the invisible chair?"
-The green screen.
-The "Star Trek" guest.
You did it. Dude, you hit
a home run with that.
That was such a good idea.
Here's the idea.
So, Drew is like,
"Here's my first guest."
I think it was
Lucy Liu and Cameron Diaz maybe.
They come walking out,
they sit on a chair,
and we're in quarantine.
You go, "No, no, no."
What? They're in your --
What? How is this happening?
-Yeah.
-It was totally --
They were in L.A.
Or Cameron was in L.A.
-Cameron was in L.A.
Lucy was in the studio.
-That freaked me out.
It was amazing.
But Cameron walks out like
she's walking on your studio.
It doesn't look like a puppet
or something.
It looks like a human being.
It's brilliantly done.
You know who gave you props?
I don't know if --
You probably saw this.
Oprah. Oprah Winfrey gave you --
she did an interview.
I know, yeah, exactly.
-I can't believe it!
-Yeah, Oprah gave you --
That's when you know
you're doing well, right,
when Oprah's like,
"I saw what Drew Barrymore did
and I wanted to do that."
-I mean, just -- You know?
-Not bad.
-But I'm glad because now
we can all embrace this.
I mean, it's, like,
we're here on this show
and it's a big deal now.
This used to be so status quo.
No one thought about this.
-No.
-And now to have a live person?
Some people --
-We're so happy to have you.
[ Applause ]
-It's a big deal!
-It's a giant deal.
-It makes us appreciate it.
-I am so appreciative.
You brought us a clip.
Here's a look at
"The Drew Barrymore Show."
Take a look at this.
-For anyone watching,
can you guess which one of us
isn't really here?
-[ Gasps ]
-Welcome back!
-I'm the one in Los Angeles.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-You got to try this.
It's so incredible.
The ether, the little particles
going out into space
and coming back and remassing
into this beautiful space.
You guys, it's crazy.
You should try it.
It tingles.
[ Laughter ]
-It tingles. You got to try it.
"The Drew Barrymore Show"
airs weekdays.
Check your local listings or go
to thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
for more info.